Boa tarde a todos
Venho aqui falar sobre a informação
extraída do movimento,
que é uma informação
vital para toda a gente.
Antes de mais, permitam-me abordar
o tema do TEDxOporto
que é 'The Main Thing'.
Porque acho que a maior parte
das Main Things são conquistas coletivas.
Pelo menos, todas as minhas são.
Eu queria fazer aqui um singelo
reconhecimento
ao Instituto de Engenharia de Sistemas
e Computadores do Porto, o INESC TEC.
Faço já uma declaração de interesses:
nunca fui investigador,
nem nunca trabalhei no INESC TEC.
Por isso, é que esta história
é mais interessante,
porque, quando eu os procurei,
quando eu queria começar a minha empresa,
para me ajudarem a desenvolver
uma parte importante da tecnologia,
no final dessa reunião disseram-me
que gostaram tanto da ideia
que me perguntaram se eu estaria
interessado que investissem na empresa
em troca desse conhecimento de graça.
A partir daí, acompanharam-me sempre,
particularmente nos maus momentos.
É sempre muito bom ver o que é
que uma ideia otimista atrai.
Mas voltemos ao movimento.
Mover, como foi dito aqui pela Sandra,
é tão natural como respirar.
Mas são duas coisas de que nós
não temos uma noção consciente.
Isso é, na realidade, importante.
Trago-vos aqui hoje um vídeo
para nos relembrar
a relevância do movimento na nossa vida
e ao longo de toda a nossa vida.
Até já.
(Vídeo)
(Fim de vídeo)
Espantoso, não é?
As memórias mais fortes
que temos na nossa vida
estão todas relacionadas
com o movimento
É absolutamente fascinante sempre que
nós conseguimos ver o movimento de alguém
ou a linguagem corporal.
Conseguimos perceber muita coisa
da tremura de uma mão,
dum beijo,
duma forma de andar.
Isso levou-me à minha Main Thing.
Será que era possível construir aparelhos
que conseguissem extrair
essa informação,
interpretá-la, gerar valor com ela?
Então, fui ver o que é que existia
que pudesse servir para isso.
Existem uma data
de dispositivos fantásticos
dentro de laboratórios.
Mas não conseguem medir
os movimentos do dia-a-dia.
Existem outras tecnologias, muito básicas,
que medem atividade, tal como o pedómetro.
Existem outras que tentam interpretá-la.
Existem hoje muitas coisas,
duma forma ridícula,
tentar interpretar, por exemplo,
a qualidade do sono,
através do movimento de um braço.
E vi aí uma oportunidade.
Achei que havia aqui
uma lacuna para preencher.
Mas, mais do que isso, a minha ambição
ia um bocado acima disso.
Será possível construir aparelhos
que extraiam o mesmo conhecimento
que os nossos sentidos têm desse movimento?
E assim, em 2006, munido de um protótipo
desenvolvido na Faculdade de Engenharia
por uns investigadores,
que tinham um algoritmo que media a marcha,
a forma de andar das pessoas,
comecei este projeto.
Para terem uma ideia
do que é que se pode fazer
com essa informação de movimento,
um movimento aqui não muito trivial,
de como desenvolvemos um dispositivo
para utilizar informação do movimento
ou da inação de pacientes acamados,
para aumentar a eficiência da enfermagem.
Eu adoro a atividade dos enfermeiros.
Eu tinha escrito "eu adoro enfermeiras"
mas a minha mulher decidiu
vir aqui e tive que alterar.
(Risos)
Os enfermeiros são um dos recursos
mais escassos dos hospitais e dos lares
e é incrível como, no século XXI,
pouca tecnologia
tinha sido desenvolvida para os ajudar.
Eu gosto deles porque são como os Sioux,
têm que decidir muito rapidamente,
com informação muito incompleta,
muitas vezes sabendo
que poderão ter uma má decisão
mas que, mesmo assim,
é melhor do que nenhuma decisão.
e nada existe para os ajudar.
Aquilo a que nós nos dedicamos
é uma tarefa que ocupa
muito tempo aos enfermeiros
e que, por vezes, é muito desconfortável
para os pacientes,
o reposicionamento dos pacientes acamados.
Alguns porque são idosos e correm o risco
de desenvolver úlceras ou escaras,
outros porque têm problemas respiratórios.
Por exemplo, uma pessoa com pneumonia,
na posição errada, pode morrer.
Ou problemas cardíacos.
Como é que se faz isso hoje?
Metem-se todos os pacientes numa rotina,
para evitar falhas.
Isso dá um trabalho acrescido
aos enfermeiros,
têm que reposicionar pessoas
que não precisam de ser reposicionadas,
porque alguns têm capacidade de se mover,
outros têm capacidade de se mover
mas estão sob o efeito de sedativos
e não se movem naturalmente.
Por outro lado, reposicionam pacientes
que estavam a dormir
e que não querem ser incomodados
porque têm as suas atividades normais.
O que nós fizemos
foi um simples dispositivo
que monitoriza o movimento dos pacientes.
Podem ser 10, 100, 1000,
num ou vários edifícios,
e faça isso por um simples "dashboard"
que pode ser visto num tablet
ou num smartphone,
que permite aos enfermeiros saber
quem se está a mexer bem,
quem não está se está a mexer bem,
reduzindo assim o seu trabalho
e deixando de incomodar os pacientes.
É o que eu chamo eficiência.
Mas há uma parte
que ainda nos interessa muito mais.
A primeira grande distinção do ser humano
em relação aos outros animais
é a locomoção bípede.
A maior parte dos antropólogos acredita
que, como essa função bípede
consome muito menos energia
do que quando andávamos
com os quatro membros,
essa energia foi usurpada pelo cérebro
para fazer a segunda grande distinção
do ser humano em relação
aos outros animais
que foi ter racionalidade.
Isso levou a que os pés
sejam a única parte desenhada
para estar em contacto com o chão.
Assim, os pés são fantásticos
porque são repositórios de informação
de tudo o que nós fazemos
com o nosso corpo.
Se eu me inclino,
isso tem um reflexo nos meus pés.
Então, nós decidimos dedicar-nos
a tentar extrair informação dos pés,
particularmente aquilo que é chamado
a pressão plantar,
ou seja, a distribuição na planta do pé,
quando pousa no chão
e ao longo do percurso, pelo chão.
Isso é único, cada um de nós
tem uma forma diferente de andar,
um bocado como as nossas
impressões digitais,
o que tornou isso
muito mais interessante
porque, quando há uma alteração
consistente do padrão da marcha,
isso, normalmente,
é um indicador de que existe
ou um problema físico
ou um problema neurológico.
Imaginem que os vossos sapatos
são inteligentes
e conseguem detetar
essa alteração do padrão
e que vos é detetado Alzheimer,
que vos é detetado 10 anos mais cedo
do que o que seria normal.
Conseguem imaginar a qualidade de vida
que vão ter no resto desses anos
por ter sido detetada essa doença
numa fase muito precoce?
Isto é aquilo que pode ser conseguido
através da informação dos pés.
Eu vou mostrar um pequeno vídeo,
também com um dispositivo nosso,
que permite ver um paciente com AVC,
que, neste caso, sou eu, a simular.
que posiciona o pé afetado,
primeiro pela parte da frente
e depois pela parte de trás.
Vocês não têm ideia da energia
que o andar consome
e do que esta gente consome
para conseguir tentar andar normalmente.
Mas, depois de aplicadas umas ortóteses
consegue posicionar o pé da forma correta
e, com isso, poupar
um conjunto de problemas,
como seja, a falta de confiança,
o poder cair,
e, inclusive, melhorar a sua performance.
Uma das coisas que nós também descobrimos
é que isto funciona ao contrário,
ou seja, se nós tivermos alguma alteração
na forma de andar
isto tem efeitos físicos
e tem efeitos neurológicos.
Isso é ainda mais fantástico.
Uma das coisas que nós pensamos logo
para poder usar esta informação,
seria o desporto.
Uma das coisas que associamos
a uma organização daqui do Porto
é a Run4excellence que treina atletas,
profissionais e recreativos,
e fomos extrair informação do que é
que era necessário para a corrida.
para corredores, pessoas que querem
que a sua atividade física seja correr.
Uma das coisas que descobrimos
é que existem imensos dispositivos
para medir o ritmo cardíaco,
para medir o ritmo da corrida,
um conjunto incrível de coisas.
Mas não existe nada para avaliar
a técnica do corredor.
Saber como é que ele correu.
Então, decidimos fazer
um dispositivo simples
e tornar esta tecnologia acessível a todos
para avaliar a técnica desses corredores
dando a possibilidade ao corredor banal
de ter informação que, até agora,
só os corredores de elite possuíam,
de forma a poderem melhorar a sua prática
medindo as suas performances
— toda a gente gosta de competir —
mas também, ao mesmo tempo,
evitando lesões.
Isto é o que nós temos conseguido fazer
com a exploração
da informação do movimento.
Eu andei à procura de fotografias.
Sou um rapaz do Porto
e queria fotografias
de raparigas ou rapazes do norte
que tivessem ganho corridas.
Então, só descobri mulheres.
A Aurora Cunha, a Vanessa Fernandes,
a Rosa Mota e a Fernanda Ribeiro.
Eu não sei se isso quer dizer
que, aqui no norte,
só as raparigas é que valem alguma coisa.
Só hoje é que aprendi
que só nós é que somos daltónicos
e, ainda por cima,
não temos orgasmos múltiplos.
Muito obrigado.
(Aplausos)